my name is michael coffey i am a custom
metalworking fabricator i really love
being able to have a picture in my mind
of an item i'd love to create and then
seeing that come into being
my name is alexey philia i was born in
russia moved to united states about 12
years ago i got into making armor first
but when you work alongside with a whole
bunch of blade smiths you start making
blades of your own
mike
ilya congratulations you've made it
through to the final round now we're
sending you home where you will forge an
iconic weapon from history
the spike shield
dating back to prehistoric times the
shield is the oldest form of protection
designed to block attacks from weapons
like spears swords axes or arrows
over time they have varied greatly in
size and construction using materials
such as steel wood animal hide and even
turtle shells
used primarily as a defense weapon the
shield can also be used to attack by
punching an opponent with either its
face or rim
sometime around the middle ages spikes
were incorporated adding an extra level
of brutality to its design the long
steel spike could deliver deadly blows
oftentimes immediately disemboweling the
attacker the most notable spiked shields
today can be seen in the popular video
game series skyrim
your challenge is to forge a spiked
shield a concave weapon used by infantry
troops between 13th and 16th centuries
i'm very excited to go into round three
the most pride i have in proceeding is
having the opportunity to show
my armoring skills
i really enjoy doing shields but i was
not expecting to have to do any sort of
spikes or weird crap like that
[Music]
and i've assumed that i would make it to
the final challenge but here i am
now that i'm back on my own forge i feel
very excited
shields require the skills of an armor
so i do have an advantage over blade
makers in completing this project
i'm designing a shield with an attached
gauntlet the gauntlet is a steel glove
so this covers the back of the palm the
wrist and a partial forearm the gauntlet
can now be integrated into the shield
i'm feeling pretty good
for the shape of the spike i use the
world war one bayonet construction as my
inspiration
i'm also going to position blade
catchers when the spear or any other
thrusting weapon comes in they get
caught underneath its trap it further
improves the durability of the shield
i've laid out all the pieces and i have
to say
this weapon rocks as far as the final
test goes i think my shield will put up
a decent fight against whatever they
throw at it
well take a look i think it's ready for
the judges
i'm feeling pretty great about being
back at the shop i share a shop with
three other forage and fire winners it's
a bit of pressure but i'm pretty
comfortable here the material i'm going
with i got enough there to cut one full
circle i've got the pieces essentially
prepped for assembly but just getting
frustrated with the alignment of all
these
pieces
again this is the worst this is the
worst
okay i gotta switch gears
this may or may not come together i
gotta get the strap i gotta get the
spike
i think i'm gonna forgo the additional
spikes um the one i have in the center
that'll be very sturdy once i get it in
place
about 20 minutes left and i need to
attach the handle and the strap where's
the
handle
the
oxy didn't hold everything is going
wrong right at the last minute
[Applause]
glad i started with a spike
it's done
it's a shield it's got a spike it's got
a handle and a strap it matches all of
the minimum requirements it'll be able
to be tested this can turn out just fine
gentlemen welcome to the arena to
perform the types of tests that we want
to with your spike shields we decided to
leave the forge in lieu of a place a
little bit more
medieval we're now going to be putting
your weapons through a series of three
tests first up the strength test ilia
you're up you ready
yes i am
there's no way the crossbow is going to
harm the shield maybe scratch it a
little bit but scratches just happen
well i can see where the bolts hit ilia
small impact there here
and right there nothing that would have
been threatened the the man behind this
shield so that's very well done
michael you're up you ready i think so
let's do this all right
i'm kind of biting my nails a little
concerned about this but i think as long
as things go straight on it'll do just
fine
well michael i can see where one hit
give a bit of a dimple
one impacted somewhere on the center
boss you could actually hear it
[Music]
and though there are some cosmetic
issues with your shield
it certainly held up to the strength
test
so well done thank you
doug
blade spitz this is the keel test
with your shield i will take four hits
on this ballistics dummy that's wearing
chainmail elia you're up are you ready
yes i am
the kill test is the one i'm a little
bit concerned about i don't know what
kind of moves doug is going to try on
the dummies
the shield feels good in the hand i can
maneuver in different ways not only to
protect
but also
to attack
now let's see how much damage it did
the killing blows
right here where it penetrated all the
way that's to the sternum and into the
lung
in
that is
in the belly that goes all the way into
this ballistic dummy
it's disgusting i can only imagine what
a real body would have incurred with a
weapon like that your shield
and the spike
will kill
mike it's your turn you ready all right
uh mike your spike's a little bit loose
let's see how it goes in the test we'll
see
mike it feels good in the hand
you can strike with the edges
you can accompany it with the other hand
it moves well
the spike did hold up now let's see how
much damage we did all right
god your spike definitely penetrated on
both punctures right here probably where
the diaphragm is and in the abdomen
right here all the way through
your shield
will kill
thank you
i'm feeling really good right now
according to doug it does cue
blade spits this is a sharpness test i
will attach your shield to this
mechanical device i will then release
your shield to see if it'll puncture the
steel drum if your spike is sharp it
should go in easily if not well it may
just dent the drum
ela you're up are you ready yes i am
three two one engaging
well ilya your spike went cleanly
through the drum and all the way out i
don't see any problems or any
deformations on your spike so it held up
very well good job thank you mike you're
up are you ready oh yeah let's do this
the lack of a secure connection on that
spike has definitely given me a bit of
anxiety looking at this test coming up
here
and in three two one engaging
well mike
your spike went all the way through got
stuck a little bit
came out cleanly but i do not see any
damage to your spike good job sir thank
you
winning is a matter of principle and the
principle is you play for victory
what i'm looking forward to is breaking
the winning streak of
michael's forge the judges have
scrutinized your work and they've made a
final decision about which of you is the
forged and fire champion who will
receive a check for ten thousand dollars
ilya
you are the forged empire champion
congratulations thank you
mike
your shield did not make the cut
mike in this competition performance
over fit and finish is key but there
were just too many unfinished pieces
with your shield to move on
mike
please surrender your shield
thank you john this is a fantastic
experience considering the pressure of
having three previous winners in the
same shop i think i performed very well
so as much as i would have liked a win
this still feels like a victory
ilya congratulations you are the forged
and fire champion and will be receiving
a check for ten thousand dollars
thank
you the way that all works together i
mean
just fantastic piece i think i'm fairly
satisfied with the end result i might
not
often show it but trust me i am proud
the prize money is already pretty much
spent on student loans and my
girlfriend's education and astrophysics
i'm the fortune fire champion and it
feels
pretty good
you